We're not storing a key piece
of data in our weather table,
the location at which
the weather is going to occur.
This is because we are going to use
a separate table for weather locations.
Using a separate table
has several advantages.
In addition to being more efficient
because we do not duplicate our location
data with each record, it also allows
us to update information about our
location without having to update
every weather forecast record.
To implement this, we're going to create
a relation between our weather and
location tables by adding a column to
the weather table that refers to an ID
in the location table.
This column is created with a constraint
that identifies it as a foreign key,
which is a unique ID from another table.
What does this look like?
Our list of columns in the weather
table has a location ID,
which points to IDs in
the location table.
We can use this location ID to perform
an operation known as an inner join.
Inner joins combine the data queried
from two rows in different tables into
one row in the results.
When we create our tables in this
way we can get any combination of
columns from both tables.
In this case we're getting the location
query from the location table, and
the date, description, and min and
max temperature from the weather table